well centennial hills hospital going to  be expanding its services to its first  free-standing emergency department it's  going to be located right here near the  corner of elkhorn and decatur boulevard  this is up in north las vegas if you're  familiar with it it's not too far from  the dmv kind of a landmark for you  the er at valley vista is actually going  to be an extension  of the hospital's existing emergency  department the facility is going to  feature a medical exam rooms  advanced imaging services along with  on-site decontamination rooms as well  the er expected to open they haven't  even broken ground yet sometime at the  end of this year kirsten